[Music]
I've got a chance to talk to Anderson
Career Service Dalton Kathy Griffin in
tears addressing her firing from CNN a
press conference was held Friday morning
regarding the controversial images of
the comedian holding a bloody head
resembling President Donald Trump I
don't think I will have a career after
this I think he I think he I think he
I'm gonna be honest he broke me he broke
me and then I was like oh this is it
right it's about right and I apologize
because I was the right thing to do and
I meant it
and then I saw the tide turning and I
saw what they were doing I went oh okay
they're trying to spin this or they're
making about baron and obviously that
was never my intent I would never want
to hurt anyone much less a child but I
started to see what was really happening
and then it was a mob mentality pile on
and so many people have expressed to me
personally across the country at my
shows they're scared so yeah I don't
know what's I don't know if I made that
arrest I don't know
[Music]